des températures estivales un déjeuner
face à la mer mais la vie d'avant le
kovy 19 loin d'avoir repris son cours le
mot confinement plus que jamais
d'actualité sur la croisette bah oui
parce que bon vous avez vu le temps
qu'on a il fait très très beau les gens
si vous regardez les trois quarts ils
ont le masque la donc voila moi je pense
que les gens ne respectent pas vraiment
le masque tout le temps à l'extérieur
quoi en espérant qu en confinant ça
passe du bien que sa puce
être confiné que les gens respectent et
puis que par la suite on puisse être un
petit peu plus libre maintenant
l'histoire de confiner le week-end faut
essayer
faut voir on va essayer pendant deux
week-ends voire 4 parce qu'à mon avis
deux week-ends c'est trop juste
on peut pas dire si c'est valable ou pas
on verra l'avenir nul durant les deux
prochains week end sous le signe donc de
la responsabilité citoyenne du vendredi
18 heures à lundi 6 heures les sorties
d'une heure autorisé mais seulement pour
motif impérieux travail rendez vous
médical promenade jusqu'à 5 kilomètres
autour du domicile
[Applaudissements]
après le confinement pour le week-end
bonjour s était quand même dubitatif
parce que moi je sais pas si ça va ça
vient vraiment à quelque chose que les
gens la semaine vont se concentrer plus
la semaine et moins sortir le week-end
moi je descends je sais ma marche avant
de venir au boul je passe par le succès
c'est tout fermé ça fait drôle quoi donc
c'est vrai que ça touche énormément
d'un point de vue économique c'est dur
c'est dur pour les champs et des cannois
sceptiques et compatissant envers les
restaurateurs et travailleurs du
dimanche
aujourd'hui les commerces de plus de
5000 m² sont fermés les magasins de
première nécessité les pharmacies ou
encore les enseignes de bricolage et
jardinage sont exemptés d'une fermeture
aux conséquences dévastatrices
à l'image de ce restaurant le plus vieil
établissement de cannes créée en 1860 le
kabuto prisée par les célébrités dispose
de 200 couverts aujourd'hui la joie et
l'effervescence a laissé place à la
colère
nos personnels sont reclus chez eux sont
en dépression
on est en train de tuer les forces vives
de ce pays un enfant de d'appauvrir et
de et de paupériser complètement nos
commerces nos restaurants et nos
brasseries laissé à nous chefs
d'entreprise le soin de prendre soin de
nos clients ces mesures qui sont prises
sur notre région
mais sur les alpes maritimes elles sont
la conséquence unique de cette vague
migratoire qui arrivent d'italie et qui
n'est pas stoppée à noter également que
les commerces de plus de 400 mètres
carrés sont autorisées à rester ouvert
sans grande affluence
une nouveauté un médiateur qu'ovide
parmi les salariés devra veiller au
respect strict des gestes barrières